si chers collègues l'ordre du jour
appelle la question orale numéro 578 de
gérard bailly un mission mise de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie
la parole est à gérard bailly auteurs la
question madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je voudrais appeler votre
attention ce matin monsieur ministe sur
les difficultés que rencontrent les
propriétaires forestiers et les communes
pour l'exploitation de leurs forêts
lorsque celle ci se trouve dans les
territoires aux zones classées pour la
protection des amphibiens et des
reptiles des insectes mammifères oiseaux
c'est dans les départements qui ont de
grands espaces où s'appliquent de forte
réglementation il ya des mises en place
d' arrêté de biotope mise en place de
réserves naturelles sans que les
propriétaires concernés reçoivent en
amont beaucoup d'informations des
services de l'état ce qui s'apparente à
des mesures confiscatoire leur imposant
une sur administration avec des demandes
d'autorisation pour tout et n'importe
quoi parfois même au détriment de la
sécurité publique
suite à des mises en place de
réglementations strictes stricte pardon
pour des activités traditionnelles
économique ou même des de loisirs ils
auront de plus l'obligation de réaliser
de coûteuses études d'incidents dans le
cadre de natura 2000 à leur charge bien
sûr ou à la charge des acteurs locaux
pour permettre les activités forestières
agricoles ou des manifestations
sportives l'importance de la
biodiversité je croquerais d'en parler
et du développement durable n'est pas
contestée mais pourra-t-on encore
longtemps faire comme si on oubliait que
ces espaces sont le fruit du travail des
hommes et que c'est ce qui a permis la
diversité et la richesse de ces
territoires
vouloir les mettre sous cloche elle aura
des effets très négatives tant du point
de vue humain qu'en termes de
biodiversité
dernièrement c'est au mois de juillet un
arrêté de biotope le 5 juillet a été
publiée dans le département du jura qui
concerne 69 sites sur 99 territoires
communaux pour une superficie totale de
1643 hectares qui vient s'ajouter déjà à
d'autres territoires
on connaît l'importance de l'hiver dans
le massif du jura d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
les blancs et puis on annonce beaucoup
de neige après demain on connaît
l'importance de l'hiver dans le massif
du jura vous souvent dès novembre les
forêts ne sont plus accessibles
or l'arrêté interdit les activités
sylvicoles exploitation forestière du 15
février au 15 juin
et si le grand et rae présents sur ces
mêmes territoires
le calendrier d'interdiction d'entrée
afin d'exploiter ces parcelles s'étale
du 15 décembre au 1er juillet et je
pense que l'été non plus juillet-août ne
sont pas des périodes les plus propices
à l'exploitation forestière d'ailleurs
loué nef interdit la pratique de
l'affouage pas d'aller couper du bois à
compter du 15 avril ou du 1er mai sur
l'altitude dans ces forêts alors vous
voyez les contraintes que peuvent avoir
les propriétaires et toutes ces
contraintes compliquer de façon
significative dans l'exploitation
forestière j'y viens de dire mme de ces
territoires
mais je voudrais évoquer aussi les
difficultés dans ces parcelles lorsqu'il
y a un petit ruisseau et qu'il faut la
traversée d'un pour sortir son bois les
difficultés qu'on peut avoir aussi là
avec la police de l'eau alors j'aimerais
que vous me disiez monsieur le ministre
comment les propriétaire dépossédé
partiellement de leurs biens bon pouvoir
obtenir exonérations ou compensation
pour toutes ces servitudes je souligne
que seules des contrats de non gestion
forestière sont proposés actuellement ce
qui est une absurdité totale pour tous
les civils culteurs car contraire à
l'objectif de dynamisation de notre
filière forestière et bien sûr et
principalement aussi de tous cas la
filière bois énergie que le gouvernement
que vous soutenez par ailleurs et c'est
bien à la fois dans le budget 2014 dans
la future leurs lois agricoles
alors monsieur le ministre croit y est
vous pas quand même qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de contradictions
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à mme ce ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur gérard bailly le président de
la république l'a rappelé lors de la
deuxième conférence environnementale la
france dispose de la plus merveilleuse
forêt et la promotion de la filière bois
est notre priorité celles du jura ne
fait pas exception à la faire je me
félicite que les acteurs de cette
filière dont les forestiers soit
d'ailleurs désormais présents au sein du
conseil national de la transition
écologique la leur permet de s'exprimer
et pour pérenniser ce trésor de la
biodiversité française différents
dispositifs et types de protections
adaptées aux situations locales existent
les arrêtés de protection de biotope
notamment son prix pour répondre aux
besoins de protection spécifique
d'espèces protégées du fait de leur
rareté et de leur vulnérabilité
ces dispositifs ont bien sûr l'objet de
consultation et de concertation
l'arrêté de protection de biotope du 5
juillet 2013 que vous mentionnez pris
par le préfet du jura n'est en fait pas
nouveau puisqu'il correspond une
actualisation d'un arrêté datant du 2
juin 1982 ces effets sont d'ailleurs
limité dans l'espace et dans le temps il
concerne une faible partie des falaises
calcaires du département avec un ciblage
sur les corniches les pentes et bas de
pente
ces falaises sont des sites et enjeu
majeur pour le cycle de vie des espèces
menacées que sont le faucon pèlerin et
le grand-duc la concertation préalable
sur ce texte n'a pas donné lieu à
beaucoup de réactions un seul retour
d'un forestier a été d'ailleurs
enregistré la concertation avec les
organismes sportifs dont ceux du vol
libre à elle conduit à un partage de
l'espace afin de concilier ses activités
avec la protection de ces espèces
les échanges avec les forestiers avec
l'office national des forêts le centre
régional de la propriété forestière la
chambre d'agriculture et le syndicat des
propriétaires forestiers ont quant à eux
permis d'adapter le règlement à la
réalité des pratiques les incertitudes
qui aurait pu peser notamment sur les
travaux de desserte et l'implantation
d'abris pour les forestiers ont ainsi
été levés
ces discussions ont aussi permis de
préciser la cartographie pour répondre
précisément à vos interrogations
l'arrêté n'interdit pas l'exploitation
forestière mais règlement pendant quatre
mois l'utilisation de moteurs thermiques
il s'agit d'éviter le dérangement en
particulier en période de reproduction
les forestiers avec lesquelles cette
concertation a été conduite semble avoir
bien compris les enjeux et n'ont pas
jugé ces protections incompatible avec
l'exploitation forestière dans ces
situations tout à fait particulière de
pente et de falaise je reste monsieur le
sénateur toutefois bien sûr on attentifs
à toute difficulté qui pourrait
rencontrer les forestiers dans
l'exercice de leur profession
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
bailly souhaitez-vous réagir aux propos
de monsieur ministre un petit peu quand
même
madame la présidente parce que le
ministre a sans doute bien sûr des
informations et du côté de
l'administration du jura qui pensent
qu'il ya trop de bohème mais quand on a
les articles comme ça dans après jura le
coup de gueule des forestiers privés
c'est quand même bien ils sont quand
même pas très très content et quand vous
dites quelque une réclamation
voyez les articles de presse je peux pas
les une assemblée générale à des
forestiers sans que ce problème est
évoqué donc pas question monsieur le
ministre est le porte est surtout la fin
de mon intervention sur est ce que ces
parcelles qui sont un peu gelé ou les
exploitants ne les propriétaires ne peut
plus exploiter convenablement parce que
je sais bien qu'on peut aller dans le
bois dans cette période là mais avec une
serpe
aujourd'hui je crois que l'exploitation
du bois se fait quand même avec une
tronçonneuse gens comment on peut
exploiter des bois pendant cette période
alors là aussi si vous voulez les
forestiers il invite aussi les gens à
venir couper le bois pendant ces quatre
mois avec une serre pour une hache ou le
passe partout comme j'ai fait quand
j'étais gamin c'est aussi possible mais
pour l'instant il n'y a pas beaucoup de
candidats pour ça alors c'est pour ça
qu'on irait que des 302 d'armes smith ma
question que j'ai posée puisque le
premier ministre a annoncé hier une
réforme de la fiscalité au moins que des
procès par celle là qui apporte beaucoup
à la biodiversité à notre environnement
et bien n'est pas la même fiscalité la
même que les autres parcelles
alors si on veut tenir ces contraintes
il faudra qu'on trouve des solutions
parce qu'autrement monsieur le ministre
un petit peu comme natura 2000
c'est un des dossiers qui vous cacher
naturellement et puis c'est logique
et bien si on s'il n'y a pas des
compensations
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le monde rural
ne voudra plus de toutes ces contraintes
donc c'est plutôt je voudrais que mon
intervention servent un petit peu à dire
il faudra trouver des solutions
vis-à-vis de la fiscalité pour ces
parcelles compte des contraintes
particulières
merci de m'avoir écouté mes sept
ministres
merci chers collègues